y 21 años han pasado desde que bashar
al-assad fue proclamado presidente por
primera vez este sábado y por cuarta
ocasión prestó juramento para iniciar un
nuevo mandato
juro en nombre de dios que vamos a
respetar la constitución siria las leyes
de este país y su estructura republicana
vamos a velar por los intereses del
pueblo y sus libertades proteger la
soberanía de la nación su independencia
su libertad y la defensa de su
territorio
sin embargo su cuarta investidura se
presenta en un contexto donde el país
sigue sumido por los estragos de la
guerra más del 80 por ciento de la
población vive en la pobreza y según el
programa mundial de alimentos 12.4
millones de personas luchan por
abastecerse de comida cada día la
investidura se dio después de las
elecciones del 26 de mayo deslegitimadas
por varios países como eeuu francia y
gran bretaña en las que basilio 95.1 por
ciento de los votos además de la crisis
social en este nuevo período el
ejecutivo tendrá que retomar el control
de territorios bajo el mandato de grupos
armados el noreste del país es
controlado por la facilidad al qaeda y
sus aliados de clic mientras que las
fuerzas kurdas mantienen el dominio en
buena parte del este y tour que sus
representantes sirios controlan la parte
del norte
en su nuevo mandato al asad prometió
trabajar por mantener estos territorios
como parte de siria y darle prioridad al
proceso de reconciliación en el país
desde el comienzo de la guerra más de
medio millón de personas han sido
asesinadas y más de 12 millones han sido
desplazadas
[Música]